chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
introduces a slew of new characters to
the marvel cinematic universe with all
the new faces it's easy to miss the
deeper significance of a few of them
here are all the characters from chongqi
that are more than meets the eye the
dweller in darkness in chongqi is
something of a counter-dragon to the
great protector he has spent centuries
trying to break out of the dark gateway
and finally managed to do so after
tricking wenwoo into breaking down the
barrier with the ten rings he proceeds
to suck up the souls of many villagers
and combatants before being defeated the
comic book version of the dweller in
darkness is a frequent villain of doctor
strange as well he's a cthulhu-like
demon with little physical or
biographical resemblance to what we see
in the shanghi movie in the film he is
actually an alien who came to earth long
ago bringing with him others of his kind
and the ten rings there's also a pretty
decent chance that the dweller in
darkness is a reimagined finn fang foom
a diabolical dragon from the comics and
a creature that's popped up throughout
the marvel universe
captain marvel's appearance in the
mid-credits scene is in many ways
traditional mcu world building after
spending almost the entire movie doing
their own thing chongqi and katie
finally meet up with wong bruce banner
and carol danvers to discuss the rings
this is obviously the opening salvo to
future chi adventures and avengers style
crossovers but it's not necessarily
carol who means more than it appears
it's brie larson herself director destin
daniel [ __ ] has four director credits
to his name prior to chongqing of those
four the last three just mercy the glass
castle and short term 12 all feature
brie larson he's been there for many
phases of her career with short term 12
often listed as her first true dramatic
lead and knew her well before she won an
oscar for room or became captain marvel
that makes chongqi the fourth time
they've worked together even if this
particular appearance was a brief one
villainous monster the abomination makes
a brief appearance in chongqi fighting
long and shaolin's fighting ring this
marks his first appearance in the mcu
since the incredible hulk and his chummy
relationship with wong hints that this
is just the start of abomination's new
status in marvel's shared universe even
though he hasn't been seen on screen in
more than a decade abomination has
loomed in the background for years in
the 2011 short the consultant agent phil
coulson said that the powers that be
wanted abomination assigned to the
avengers initiative coulson was against
this and sent tony stark to tank
negotiations abomination was also
name-dropped in an episode of agents of
shield where the audience was informed
the one-time hulk foe was still
imprisoned i'll reassign you to barrow
alaska and you'll spend the rest of your
years pulling the night shift guarding
blotsky's cryocell
how and why abombination ended up
friendly with wong remains unknown what
is known is that tim roth is set to
reprise the role of abomination in the
upcoming she-hulk disney plus series as
such this part in shanghai is more than
just a cameo it's a sign of things to
come
though he's never named on screen and
stays silent throughout the picture's
runtime death dealer looms large over
the proceedings of chongqi he's present
for shang chi's grueling training as a
child and acts as wenwu's right-hand man
later in life he's rewarded for this
loyalty by getting eaten up by a
so-called soul sucker a victim of his
boss's misguided quest though it's
barely explored on screen death dealer
does have a brief albeit notable comics
history death dealer was lieutenant for
fu manchu shang chi's father in the
comics he was brutal and willing to do
anything to advance his position fu
manchu is the one who provided death
dealer with the mask and weapons death
dealer also had an obsession with
playing cards hence the name he came to
his end just a few issues after his
introduction with chongqi burning the
villain alive though death dealer
himself has stayed dead all these years
he did manage to leave something behind
a son in 2009 a shang chi master of kung
fu one-shot comic had chongqi facing off
against wolee the junior to death
dealers frank grimes might we see huoli
in future mcu adventures only time will
tell
if you haven't read the comics or
weren't paying all that close attention
in the theater the name razorfist should
make the character in question easy to
identify a mercenary with a razor for a
fist he's hired by wenwu to track down
chongqi the two have several
altercations before ultimately working
together to stop the soul suckers there
have been three razor fists in the
comics the first appeared in a three
issue master of kung fu arc in 1979.
unlike the movie he had razors on each
hand he died after his brief run meaning
that he arguably got more development
over the course of a two-hour movie than
he ever did in the comics
i lost my hand
the second and third razorfist debuted
in 1981 in the form of brothers william
and douglas scott the two were in a car
accident with each losing an arc the
villainous carlton velcro gave each of
the scott brothers a sword arm and not
long after shot and killed douglas
williams has since bounced around as a
minor villain and henchmen it's not
known which of the three possible
candidates is the razer fist we see in
the xiang chi and the legend of the 10
rings movie but his survival means
perhaps we could learn his true identity
and backstory in some future mcu project
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
xiang chi and the legend of the 10 rings
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]